these fallen movies Olympus has fallen
London has fallen they try to capture
the cheesy action greatness of the 80s
and 90s and they do capture the spirit
of those action movies because generally
speaking in those eras for those genres
the sequels were just never as good
London has fallen so London has fallen
is the sequel to the surprisingly
entertaining Olympus has fallen with
both of these movies you got to know
what you're getting into and you're
getting into action cheesefest fun and
in his movie Gerard Butler's the Maine
Secret Service guys protecting aaron
eckhart who is his friend slash
president of the united states and in
london the super high-profile figure has
died to all these world leaders are
there for his funeral and then the [ __ ]
goes down and terrorists start wiping
people out cities scale style we've made
a bigger net and I'm gonna start with
the positives because I like starting
out with the positives optimist right
here Gerard Butler can we just say that
he's just a complete badass dude in the
last act of this movie I didn't know if
he was channeling his inner Solid Snake
arisen er John wick or a love child of
both I don't know I don't care point is
I was looking at meals like you're
pretty [ __ ] cool dude and Aaron
Eckhart not only our Aaron Eckhart and
Gerard Butler good actors but they have
great chemistry in this movie I really
bought the fact that Gerard Butler isn't
trying to say the President of the
United States he's trying to save his
friend however this movie should have
known that bigger isn't always better
this is city scale now so they're on the
run on her city scale all right Olympus
has fallen was in a building in that you
kind of compared to die hard it really
was what die hard five should have been
one Met Army in a building taking on the
baddies he's everyone's last hope this
is city scale now so you can really
compare it to die hard with a vengeance
or live free or die hard funny enough I
enjoyed both of those movies more than
London has fallen everything was bigger
but it just wasn't better and I think
that's because the director Antoine
Fuqua the director of the original
Olympus has fallen talented director
this is not directed by the same guy
ladies and gentlemen this is a different
dude the pacing in this movie was off in
just two many scenes I attribute it to
imagine Olympus has fallen okay one
building so we'll say that is one room
imagine this one room is filled with
about 50 bees small space 50 bees very
busy and it's just a little more it's
going on and so the pacing is just it
moves forward a lot faster a little more
claustrophobic and a little more
entertaining okay so let's say you have
those same 50 bees spread out in an
entire shopping mall
little slower noting Olympus has fallen
didn't have downtime I'm just there's
your metaphor man it's what you get one
thing they did not make bigger is a
visual effects budget I think that's
about the same as the original Olympus
has fallen so it was like let's keep the
visual effects budget for this may be
the same as the last movie okay you want
the same amount of visual effects no I
said more more effects with less budget
mathematically that would mean the
effects will look worse
maybe [ __ ] yeah that's how that went
down
it didn't look pretty some of it was
pretty bad and I get where it's like
well it supposed to be cheesy action
funny not supposed to look at that but
at a point when it's bad enough it does
pull you out of the movie and the last
part of this movie just wraps something
up there's this thing they got to do
it's like this extra thing I feel like
they were going to leave it for the
sequel and then the movie didn't test
well with screeners and test audiences
and they were like well we don't know if
it's gonna get a sequel let's just film
one scene to wrap it up quickly and it
wrapped up really quickly and that was
that I really feel like that's what
happened guys London has fallen tries to
springboard off of the vibe and premise
of what Olympus has fallen set up which
is 90s action movies in the 2010 and
although Gerard Butler is awesome in
this movie he's complete badass he's fun
to watch the movie that he is in the
movie that surrounds him just isn't as
entertaining if you like cheesy 90s
action movies great watch it have fun
know what you're getting into and know
that this is not as good as the original
I will say London has fallen probably a
better time if you're drunk yeah no it's
a party Gerard Butler such a badass yeah
I think everyone knows I'm a badass by
now alright so London has fallen have
you seen it what do you think about it
what's the prime example of a signal
that's just not as good as their
original whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to say more
you